Hier werden keine Lottozahlen gezogen,
sondern Einkommen verlost:
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen.
Peer würde mit dem
Grundeinkommen etwas reisen ...
Glaube, wir haben gerade das Leben
von jemandem revolutioniert.
1000 Euro jeden Monat für ein ganzes Jahr
– einfach so, ohne etwas dafür zu tun?
Klingt wie ein Wunschtraum.
Der Berliner Verein „Mein Grundeinkommen“
hat schon 53 verlost
und will so beweisen, dass es machbar ist.
Es mag utopisch klingen,
so ’n Grundeinkommen,
aber ich glaub, es wird ’ne
wirtschaftliche Notwendigkeit, denn
der Sozialstaat, wie wir ihn heute haben,
war die Antwort auf die Industrialisierung.
Und jetzt haben wir aber die Digitalisierung:
ganz neue Arbeitsverhältnisse,
viel prekärer, viel temporärer,
schneller in Veränderung,
dauerhafte Erwerbsverhältnisse
gibt’s nicht mehr.
Und die einzige Antwort, die es
darauf geben kann, die ich kenne,
ist das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen.
Eigentlich ist das, was Vereinsgründer
Michael Bohmeyer vorschlägt,
eine Revolution:
Menschen sollen grundsätzlich
finanziell abgesichert sein,
egal, ob bedürftig oder nicht.
Jeder soll ohne Existenzangst und
damit freier leben können.
Insgesamt hat es bei allen
Menschen positive Effekte,
ohne dass ich darüber
werten wollen würde.
Wir haben drei Leute,
die sich selbstständig gemacht haben.
Wir haben nur einen Einzigen, der sich
seinen … der seinen Job gekündigt hat
im Callcenter, der jetzt Pädagogik studiert.
Wir haben mehrere Menschen,
die ’ne Weiterbildung anstreben,
weil sie Lust haben,
was Neues zu machen.
Es verändert was im Kopf. Es
verändert die Haltung zum Leben,
die Haltung zu Besitz, die
Beziehungen, die ich führe,
wie ich andere Menschen betrachte,
dass ich nicht mehr Angst vor ihnen habe
oder in Konkurrenz zu ihnen stehe, sondern
dass ich ihnen wirklich begegne.
Viele Wirtschaftsexperten
sind dagegen skeptisch.
Dominik Enste forscht seit acht
Jahren zum Grundeinkommen.
Er findet die Idee gut, doch in der
Realität sei sie nicht umsetzbar.
Denn würden wirklich alle weiterarbeiten,
wenn sie auch so Geld bekommen?
Das Einkommen, das Geld,
das man bekommt,
bezeichnet man in der
Sozialpsychologie als Hygienefaktor.
Das heißt, das brauch’ man irgendwie,
dass man auch akzeptiert,
dass man sich anstrengt,
dass man Leistung erbringt,
dafür möchte man auch gerne
irgendeine monetäre Entlohnung haben.
Wenn die wegfällt oder in diesem
Fall wenn ich im Prinzip
’n relativ hohes Grundeinkommen
bekomme, ohne etwas zu leisten,
sinkt natürlich die Arbeitsmoral,
und vor allen Dingen
wird es sicherlich am Ende
schwieriger, noch Produkte
und Dienstleistungen herzustellen,
die eben nicht so viel Spaß machen.
Katrin Klink hat schon
immer viel gearbeitet.
Sie ist Grafikerin und Freiberuflerin.
Das Geld ist knapp.
Vor einem halben Jahr gewann sie
ein Grundeinkommen.
Auf die faule Haut gelegt
hat sie sich nicht.
Durch das zusätzliche Geld hatte sie
Zeit für ein Fernstudium
und ist heute Dozentin
für Gesundheitsmanagement.
Das wird mein Leben dauerhaft verändern.
Ich konnte einfach planen und
überlegen, wie investiere ich,
in was investiere ich und …
raus aus’m Alltagstrott,
also, sonst macht man einfach
immer das nächste Projekt
und das Nächste, was ansteht.
Und das war einfach ’n neuer
Schritt in ’ne neue Richtung.
Der Berliner Verein finanziert die
Grundeinkommen über Spenden.
Gesammelt wird über
eine Internetplattform,
auch Kleinstbeträge von wenigen Euro.
Anmelden und für die Verlosung
bewerben kann sich jeder –
auch ohne Spende.
Im Kleinen funktioniert das,
aber wie soll ein Grundeinkommen
für ein ganzes Land bezahlt werden?
Grundeinkommen braucht Umverteilung,
braucht möglicherweise
auch höhere Steuern.
Viele Sachen würden auch wegfallen:
neben dem Bürokratieaufwand
zum Beispiel so was wie BAfög,
ALG I, ALG II, Elterngeld, Kindergeld.
All das könnte man streichen
und durch ’n Grundeinkommen,
was ja höher wär, ersetzen.
Die Finanzierung kann man mit
50 Prozent Konsumsteuer versuchen.
Man kann hoffen, dass es keine
Schwarzarbeit gibt,
also Leute nicht versuchen,
nebenbei Geld zu verdienen,
sondern wirklich ihre Steuern bezahlen.
Man kann versuchen, Menschen
davon auszuschließen,
die nach Deutschland kommen.
Insofern zeigen aber alle Studien,
die mir vorliegen, die ich kenne,
dass es dauerhaft nicht finanzierbar ist
oder nur unter sehr utopischen Annahmen.
Sie glauben trotzdem an
das Grundeinkommen:
Mehr als 170.000 Menschen haben
an der letzten Verlosung teilgenommen.
Neun von ihnen haben ein Leben
ohne Geldsorgen gewonnen –
zumindest für ein Jahr.